we're getting
approaching our destination
so Tom name is Tom dis is over there
all right how many now we made it
until you are
Salam alaikum liquor setup how are you
nice to meet you
that's the main area you can go all over
the good things and circles from all the
historical place yes this is the eighth
this is the gate to all the historical
places right here let's go see some more
suppose
[Music]
silver 1748 the main marketplace here
they stop mall turkey go ahead over to
the Blue Mosque
the latest news back back in America
because what happens is they tried to
make Muslims seem like uncivilized and
backwards whatnot but you have this
zombie rule here this is like you know
well one of the only countries that's
paid off there is not in debt for the
most civilized or the most beautiful
countries in the world and living in
peace Muslims and non Muslims Jews
Christians Muslims Jews everybody they
have their own jobs she now goes
everything it's free so if a Christian
we just had recently you shared with me
the Muslim woman who wanted to take a
shorter lunch break
she wasn't asking for more time she was
going to take it from her lunch to just
to go and worship God to thank God and
she ended up getting fired
it's unbelievable things
I'm not acceptable no one can do this in
Turkey if he do and arrow arrow but the
question here ever the best to him why
he didn't
most of the people in this country and
if you are a Christian and you if you
ask your boss I'm a Christian and I want
my own chapel here he made me do it yeah
because he respected the children's
different beliefs and see himself or
herself as a representative of the
civilised West how can they do such
things that providing very interactive
in the face of own the leaves you can
you can give from from big examples of
small examples one of the things I
notice you know is when people talk
about being uncivilized you know it's a
small thing but a big thing is hygiene
right not only do we worship that alone
you know on the pure monotheism purity
one thing that came to mind is when you
go to the toilets here you know in
Bosnia you have the water that's coming
out you know this is a state of being
pure being clean so people want to call
Muslims uncivilized you know you just
look at the boys just look at the
toilets you can see then I understand
yeah the deep civilization of the
Muslims yeah and that's what we're here
bringing you cases of it pieces of it in
Istanbul stay tuned in what are we
coming up to now this is ya Sultan
Sultan omits not made much good yeah
yeah this is the selamat scare now we
will see in this mosque you then ice off
your mask you after the super-mo screen
you can see the top Kampala cake
but here
Islam is a gift it's a gift from the
Almighty for you so when you get beyond
all the media hype and all the false
propaganda and you really look into
Islam you'll really get to appreciate
that gift that the Creator has given for
you as a mercy to the world biggest
mosque you you stumble but now Museum of
tomorrow this was the biggest Murshid in
Istanbul they turned it into a race with
the Byzantine architecture they tried to
build bigger mosque use than it but they
only managed two hundred years after
they conquered Istanbul who turned it
into a museum conquering managed super
Muhammed computer altitude the roof
[Applause]
over here you got some really important
information and this is information it
pondered over reflected this is the
light this is the gift for humanity the
oneness of Allah of the Creator the
purpose of life all of this our love
scene is here at this blue mosque
sha la they can add this at other
mustards like in Bosnia the main mustard
airbag of a mosque you can add this
something like this an information area
where you have the five pillars
explained the articles of faith and
other very important
pieces of information that people can
really get to know what Islam is all
about
that's only through the correct
knowledge
here you have chicken over here this is
real beautiful one God one humanity one
Dean many prophets they all came with
this way of life that we live Islam
submission to the one God the Creator
and not the creation and then we over
have over here the five pillars five
pillars of the Salaam explained and the
list goes on it's very beautiful to see
very important because you can see all
the artifacts you can see all the the
museum's and you know the swords and all
the other things that are preserved and
say that they have here but the most
important thing none of those things is
gonna bring you bring you any benefit
may be nice to see but the thing they'll
bring you benefit is the truth the truth
that has been sent from the Creator as a
mercy to mankind and that's this Deen
this way of life of Islam
[Music]